qui la dernière fois qu'il a trop bu ne
s'est pas rappeler de sa soirée quand
vous et moi ces achats de faith et sue
ellen dans le jeu il faut secouer jours
non mais je bois pas bah quand je sors
je peux m'amuser et généralement je me
rappelle pas trop tout ce qui s'est
passé est généralement je regarde mon
portable je vois les textos que j'ai
envoyé jeunes merci pour le pipe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle va bien
moi je suis choqué par ce qu'il dit
parce que il démarre sa phase en disant
ils se rendent pas compte que les jags
et trahie mais les jets les jeunes y
travaillent
c'est pas des clochards c'est pas des
demandeurs d'emploi c'est pas des mecs
qui veulent du fric c'est les mecs qui
bossent [ __ ] de leur mère toute leur
vie eh bien le 20 du mois ils sont comme
ça au ils ont rien compris c'est les
mecs en colère moi je souhaite que les
jets les jeunes deviennent une
révolution mondiale on est champion du
monde de la révolution et je souhaite
que l'on aille à la chasse aux gros et
pas à la chasse aux petits comme un cran
il vient saignée des gens qui ont déjà
plus de sang dans les veines
il aurait dû dire j'ai été con
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux là alors un très bon tome et 2
commencent avance les deux là les deux
commencent avant alors dîner organisé
pour jeudi soir recul à dîner pour la
saint-valentin oui j'ai fait vous allez
dîner tous les vendredis vers 10h 18h à
nous c'est très simple c'est quand tu
veux ou tu veux je ne rigole pas demain
je vais installer un octogone on fera un
combat en début d'émission attention à
ta tante avait pris des airs de 16 kwh
moi donc tu as un cours comme a dit
franco va se calmer tu me laisse le
temps au détriment des cours on nous
avait dit que je prends quelques courts
et du bassin ou d'avion je vous sais pas
quand je veux où je veux c'est quand
vous voulez vous voulez en fait c'est ce
qu'on fera
mais te rends compte que si je gagne ça
veut dire que pour l'année prochaine tu
vas prendre un tout petit peu à fermer
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien je vais m'en occuper dès
demain ouais un impôt d'une tendance à
calais you're a rich qui me suit dégâts
sur un pool moi c'est encore un peu tôt
c'est encore un peu de tout
[Applaudissements]
le groupe abba vous nous faites chier tu
aimeras il est 19 heures 13 monfils n'a
pas compris encore que je faisais une
émission directe que je lui réponde oui
chérie assez blanc cassava chérie c'est
ma fille oui qu'est-ce que tu mon bébé
tu sais que je suis travail à je
travaille oui mais voilà bah je te fais
un gros bisou mon bébé saloum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me présente je m'appelle chamekh
j'suis partie avec un gros chèque
maintenant que j'ai de l'argent
presqu'autant que et kardashian avec
tout ça plus besoin que je ferai ce à
plein temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
bon
alors c'était pas prévu mais du coup moi
ça me donne une petite idée de venir
siéger je passe une annonce aussi du
coup pourquoi oui parce que après tout
j'aime moi je suis comme les gilet jaune
1 j'en ai marre de tirer le diable par
la queue à avec ma pauvre retraite de
misère alors je me disais en écoutant
son petit message après tout comme il ya
des jeunes qui s'emballe des cougars
pour leur pognon
pourquoi que je fais pas le contraire
c'est à dire c'est pourquoi je m'emballe
ray pas des petits jeunes pour leur
pognon aussi alors c'est si c'est vrai
alors en deux mots pour arrondir mes
fins de mois
cyril hanouna voudrais tu me pousser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
allez alors je crois que j'aurais pu
dire oui tu ne mets tu peux réfléchir
mais c'est vrai un tout c'est un gant
une part à qui joue bien au tennis
je voudrais pour mettre un grand coup
droit d'en valider mon loulou il ya
maintenant 17 ans nos chemins se sont
croisés pas vraiment par hasard car
c'est mon frère qui nous a présenté
aujourd'hui n'est plus là pour voir ce
que je suis en train de faire mais je
suis sûr qu'il doit être fier de ce que
nous sommes devenus depuis toutes ces
années
tu es mon adoré celui que je chérirai
oui je n'ai pas peur de le dire jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie je ne te le dit pas
assez souvent mais je suis fier de toi
je suis fier d'être t'accompagner dans
les bons comme dans les mauvais moments
je suis aussi très fier d'eux parce que
tu portes la famille à bout de bras et
je que je pourrai toujours compter sur
toi tu me l'a déjà prouvé par le passé
et même encore aujourd'hui grâce à toi
je suis maman de trois merveilles aux
filles et un jour je sais on portera le
même nom de famille
en fait tu l'auras compris si je suis là
aujourd'hui devant toi c'est tout
simplement pour te dire sébastien je
t'aime à l'infini et pour la visite
[Applaudissements]
certes